Russian media is facing a resurgent me
to chapter with a number of current and
former journalists being accused of
sexual harassment and other abuses
Saskia Taylor has the story it started
with a tweet it grew into a conversation
about sexual assault and harassment on a
level never seen before me too has
raised up many people and brought many
people down
we now have a verdict in the Harvey
Weinstein rape trial one of Hollywood's
best known actors Kevin Spacey the
latest high-profile star caught up in
allegations actor Anthony Rapp accusing
Spacey of making a sexual advance at a
party thirty years ago singer R Kelly
has officially been charged of ten
counts of aggravated criminal sexual
abuse involving young girls and it's
also just one tweet which has now
brought the movement to Russia's Shores
there is one vile story about the social
circuit around five years ago those guys
had a joke about the Twitter check she
got drunk at a house party and was
gang-raped there until rain autumn 2014
paddle every time he was passing the
newsroom approached almost every guy
including me trying to hug me touch
hands touch me below the waist whisper
in my ear well your sporty I was read by
Ruslan at my house party in 2018 and he
apologized
two years after everyone was aware of
the scale of the problem most of all I
was shocked by France who knew about it
all and still kept hanging out with him
these accusations have grabbed attention
because they involve names of people
known to the Russian public Sergey Pro
Stock off is a high-profile journalist
an editor of the website and became
media an outlet founded and funded by
businessman an exiled oligarch Maharaja
Kowski facing scrutiny alongside him is
his colleague and raised all the tough
who denies any wrongdoing
both have since resigned elsewhere in
the media wild allegations of world
around her face known to people since
the 90s a journalist called popular goth
who most recently was presenter of the
TV channel rain
he has apologized saying times have
changed and so have concepts of personal
space these latest revelations have also
rippled over into one of Russia's
largest banks spear Bank and triggered
an investigation into the conduct of two
employees we take this charges very
seriously and are interested in carrying
out an objective assessment of what
happened immediately after the
publication the internal security
service of Burbank initiated an internal
inquiry both employees are suspended
from their duties for the duration of
the investigation it's not the first
time that stories like this have risen
up from the darkness here in Russia a
few years ago another hashtag I'm not
afraid to speak so thousands of women
share their experiences of sexual
violence but they failed to resonate on
a national level
will this be different only time and the
conclusions of the investigations will
tell by the way almost three years on
from that first of me to tweet it's
clear that this is a movement that
continues to spark conversations across
all boundaries of space and culture
you